Elle sonne toutes les heures ou presque
la cloche de l'église du monastère donne
le ton et rythme le temps. Derrière ces
murs vivent 13 moniales qui ont choisi
d'intégrer la congrégation des
bénédictines. La plus jeune à 51 ans, la
plus âgée 90. Elles se sont toutes
engagées de manière définitive
après avoir prononcé les voeux
d'obéissance ,de pauvreté ,de chasteté et
de stabilité.
Ce matin là  il est  6h25 c'est le début
de la journée pour sœur Hallel marie
ça c'est le premier geste que vous
faites ? tout à fait je revêt
le christ c'est une croix un
grand habit en forme de croix.
Sœur Hallel Marie  commence toujours sa journée en
chantant une louange .Cela va de soi
pour celle qui dans une autre vie fut
enseignante auprès des sourds.
Tous les matins c'est le même rituel,
presque au pas de course les moniales
sont conviées aux Laudes  premier office
de la journée.
Un temps de prières chantées ,plutôt
joyeux qui célèbre la résurrection du christ.
Ce premier office dure une demi-heure.
Après les psaumes direction le
réfectoire pour le petit déjeuner.
Il est encore très tôt et il faut déjà
travailler ,pour sœur  Hallel marie c'est
la cuisine.Pourquoi vous avez de travailler ?
pourquoi j'ai besoin de travailler ?et
pourquoi vous travaillez ?pourquoi les
gens travaillent ? On est comme les autres,
on travaille d'abord pour se
nourrir ensuite pour subvenir aux
besoins de la communauté.  Pour
entretenir tous ces bâtiments
je pense qu'il faut quand même avoir un
peu de de matière pour les entretenir et
l'argent il tombe pas du ciel pour
nous non plus. Et  puis on est lié à
tous ceux qui travaillent .Le travail
fait partie intégrante de la vie
monastique et même la patronne du
monastère soeur marie caroline participe
elle aussi aux tâches domestiques
même les plus ingrates. Comme le
christ s'est mis à genoux au pied de ses disciples  ,moi je me met
au pied de mes sœurs .
Ce n’est pas forcément ce
geste symbolique qu il faut refaire tout le
temps mais c'est une façon d etre
au service de mes sœurs.
Sœur
marie caroline est aussi une
universitaire et si sa vocation ne fait
plus aucun doute aujourd'hui ses débuts
dans la vie religieuse ont été parfois
chaotiques.
Moi  ça m'a beaucoup frappé quand je suis
entrée au monastère j etais fiere de rentrer
dans une école ,une ecole
prestigieuse,une école où vous allez
apprendre l'amour .parce que j'arrivais
avec toutes mes illusions je croyais que
c'était facile et
je me suis vite aperçue  que de  supporter
ses soeurs au jour le jour ce n'était
pas forcément évident mais que j'etais là
pour apprendre.
Tous les jours je constate qu'il faut que je
réapprenne parce que j'ai des sentiments
négatifs qui m'habitent ,une certaine   violence ,j'ai
pas envie  de servir,j ai pas envie d’aimer..Soeur marie caroline a
été élu mere prieur à l'âge de 41 ans.
c'est son troisième mandat élue à
l'unanimité .Son rôle : garder l'unité de
la communauté et ce n'est pas toujours facile.
Cet après- midi là il y a réunion du
Conseil.
Là où se décident  en cercle restreint les
décisions importantes à prendre .Ce
jour-là on assiste à une petite
révolution.
L’ objectifs  permettre
à des jeunes de découvrir toujours plus
le christ comme roc et comme chemin qui
donne sens à leur vie.
Le monastère de bouzy veut ouvrir ses
portes à des jeunes pour partager sur un
temps assez long
la vie monastique au plus près. Les
habitudes des moniales en seront
forcément bouleversées .Puisque nous avons
choisi une vie de retrait ça n’est  donc pas
forcément évident  d'ouvrir ses portes
à des jeunes qui arrivent du monde avec
tout ce qu'elles sont. Il faudra
forcément les accueillir telles qu'elles
sont donc, je peux comprendre que
ça puisse générer quelques peurs
chez des soeurs .Dans un
monastère s'il y a une chose qui ne
changera probablement jamais c'est le
silence des lieux.
Ici on parle peu ou pas et le silence
commence des que l’on a dans a franchi la
clôture,
l'espace de vie réservée aux moniales.
C'est un lieu de
Silence,
et quand vous rencontrez d'autres soeurs
alors vous n'avez pas le droit de vous
parlez ?
On ne se parle pas,
on se salue ,on essaye de montrer
simplement qu’on s’ est vu
Et si on désire
se parler on  s'éloigne ,on se met dans un
coin simplement   pour essayer de ne pas gêner
tout le monde d'autant plus que c'est un
lieu qui résonne pas mal .
Même les repas sont
pris sans paroles. Seule une soeur chaque
jour fait la lecture d'un article ou
d'un ouvrage religieux .Ce matin là
c'était un extrait du livre de la
sociologue Elena Lasida sur la question
du temps. Le temps et l'argent.
C'est une phrase que l'on entend
habituellement dans le domaine
économique
car le temps  en économie est considéré
comme une ressource .
Il faut faire vite pour produire plus
en moins de temps  possible.
Le silence fait partie de votre vie ? Oui
On ne pourrais pas vivre si on était
toujours dans la parole ,ça serait
insupportable .Le  silence ce sont des
moments où l’on  se ressource
littéralement. Le silence, c'est pas un
absolu en soit dans le sens où c'est pas
un but.
C'est pour écouter quelqu'un et
pour écouter
il faut qu'on ait des moments de silence.
Par exemple pendant les repas
on est en silence et c'est
capital
en tout cas pour moi, c'est capital de ne
pas avoir à gérer la parole parce que, de
gérer la parole dans une communauté
Ça n’est  pas toujours facile.
Certes elles ont choisi une vie retirée
du monde mais cela ne veut pas dire qu’elles ne sortent jamais.
Il est formellement interdit de se moquer d'une
soeur qui conduit un vieux camion. Petit à
petit les moniales aussi se mettent à
l'écologie ou du moins au tri des
déchets, papiers, cartons, verres, tout ce qui
est recyclable sera transférée à la
déchetterie voisine.
Autrefois les soeurs ne sortaient pas, les
dentistes venaient au monastère les
médecins venaient, tout ce petit monde
venait au monastere.
Maintenant on
sort bien davantage,
il y a une soeur qui est partie  là,
elle est partie en session de chant à la
Pierre qui Vire c'est dans le
Morvan.
Et si ces sorties sont plus fréquentes
pour les soeurs cela doit quand
même rester l'exception .La vie au monastere
me suffit  je vous
dis ,c'est une vie heureuse ,je ne vois pas
pourquoi j'irai chercher ailleurs ce que
j'ai à la maison.
Et en même temps comme je
Disais, ça nous arrive de sortir
0:08:10.670,0:08:14.060
faire une session quelque part ,on est
heureuse de revenir. Je  peux vous le
dire
après une semaine , allez ouf on rentre
à la maison pour y retrouver
Notre  tranquillité.  Contente de retrouver leur tranquillité ,contente surtout
de renouer avec ce qui fait l'essentiel
de leur existence :
une vie de prière rythmée par les neuf
offices de la journée. Il est 18 heures
ce jour-là, c'est le temps de l'Oraison.
Les moniales peuvent se placer là où
elles le veulent sœur hallel marie  a
choisi de s’agenouiller. Moi je
préfère être dans cette position,
je suis bien parce que je suis détendue
et j'ai une ouverture.
si vous voulez une ouverture physique,
ça commence par le physique
Je sens  que mon coeur
s'ouvre
et je laisse l'esprit
saint pénétré en moi ,je laisse
l'esprit saint vivre en moi. Il faut
entretenir ce climat de dialogue avec
Dieu ,la prière c'est un dialogue ,on
écoute dieu et on lui répond. Donc pour
entretenir ce climat de prière
continuel
on a besoin ,parce qu'on est incarné, de
le manifester par des temps réguliers.
Sinon on ne peut pas tenir.
Entre la prière et le travail les
journées des moniales sont bien chargées
il est 21h30 sœur caroline se
dirige enfin vers sa cellule. Pour les
bénédictines
la cellule est un lieu d'intimité
essentiel pour y dormir bien sûr mais
aussi pour prier ,travailler et se
ressourcer. Oui c'est un lieu très
Important.
La  cellule d'une soeur ça n'est pas plus
de 12 m² composé d'un lit, d'une table et
d'un prix dieu et ça n'est pas forcément
austère.
J'ai déjà vu des cellules  super austères ou il n'y
a rien , moi j'ai toujours un peu
de bazar . C'est une question de
tempérament  j’ai des cartes postales oui
ça c'est moi, j'aime bien voilà.
j'ai besoin d'avoir
des
icônes et puis des livres.
J'adore bouquiner.
Etre moniale, c'est être retirée
du monde jusque dans la mort. Vous nous emmenez ou ?
Au cimetière ,nous allons rencontrer la
communauté du ciel ,ah oui c'est là où
sont enterrées toutes nos soeurs depuis
que nous sommes ici c'est à dire depuis
20 ans. Eh bien il y a maintenant 13
sœurs  au cimetière et 13 en communauté.
L'égalité ! Alors maintenant qui va gagner ?
C'est donc à quelques mètres du
monastère que sont enterrées les soeurs
de Bouzy la Forêt accompagnées par la
communauté jusqu'au dernier souffle.
Alors la dernière qui est morte c’est, soeur marie bernard
juste le 1er avril  2018 .On va fêter son
premier anniversaire, elle est morte le jour
de Pâques, le matin de Pâques. C'est quand
même magnifique ça de mourir un matin de
Pâques.
Une de mes premières paroles
ça a été  de dire Alléluia.
Et  si leur vie est principalement
tournée vers la prière et le travail,
le rire et la bonne humeur ont aussi
toute leur place. Le temps de détente
est  consacré ce jour-là à l'épluchage
des pommes. Les moniales se lâchent un peu.
Laissez-moi vous remercier soeur
marie-caroline d'avoir organisé cette
session si riche en rencontres
avec des conférence de grande qualité.
Oui j'en pouvais plus en lisant ça !C'est
quand même un critère de discernement .,la joie.
Si on sent que  quelqu'un qui  rentre au monastère
Et qui  tire toujours une tête comme ça
c'est clair et net que cette personne  n’aura
sûrement pas  vocation à rentrer
chez nous .Toutes  vous le diront, la
vie monastique n'est pas un long fleuve
tranquille ,la foi est aussi une
question d'endurance.
Chaque jour les moniales doivent avoir
la volonté de croire. Il arrive que
certaines soeurs qui ne se sentent plus
en phase avec cette vie quitte le
monastère et c'est déjà arrivé à Bouzy.
Celles qui restent ont trouvé leur
équilibre et pour rien au monde ne
changerait de vie .Souvent je  me dis , si je
devais recommencer
malgré les difficultés et les moments de
doute que j'ai eu au début  de ma
vie monastique, je recommencerai.
Parce que justement j'ai eu l'impression
de commencer un voyage intérieur,
une aventure qui n'a pas été  sans
peur et sans moments difficiles mais
pour rien au monde je ne regrette
cette vie là parce qu’elle
qu'elle m’a fait grandir.